bene tenere assieme venuti shiva questo
nuovissimo video che sono parigi serata
di screven manor quel gioco che ho
portato nel 2013 è lontano viene 13
godetevi la seconda parte ragazzi
let's go
minchia mi sono preso malissimo o
wingardium leviosa lo fai a casa tua che
a casa mia non va bene
grazie a quindi è automatico ma bene me
la ricordavo un po diversa o quattro ma
la meno stesso comunque comunque o che
abbiamo portato una stanza di quelle
superiori e sezione porto la kia la
chiave io non ho capito a che serve ma
aveva porto perché effettivamente c'era
una chiave sul tavolo prima che non ho
capito take the chiave decorata me la
porto perché non hai capito tante cose e
tipo un po come el'ho nei board sono
oggetti a caso che non sai quando li
userei mai userei prima o poi me la
porto
dobbiamo fare tutte le stanze tanto quel
pezzo di merda è morto perché salvato
non ho capito che serve a vento
questa questo e quindi sa pure signori
perché poggia la chiave ricchezze
aspetta email zurri capitale la palla di
myspace che lo fa a questi solo come se
fossero quelli del muro
vabbè fin qua però non ho ben capito che
ho trovato st palla grossa cross
forcelle aia porca tua madre che male
non mettiamo le palle a caso ecco questa
è una lezione che dovrei imparare
perfetta così sembra strano che grazie
della palla no e spiega mi scusi lo dice
jaqueline in viola dice la verità cos'è
che ama spetta a me comparso un altro
liar la iella year
allora perché effettivamente d'ora ok
questo mente jaqueline in viola dice la
verità il globo appartiene alla cornice
all'estrema sinistra
che palle se ci ha seguito il
ragionamento se uno dice la verità e gli
altri mentono vuol dire che tra cinque
mentone uno dice la verità quindi se
tutto gli 1 al 6 rimangono cinque quindi
la radice quadrata di 6 rimarrà sempre
2,9
2449 sono quindi qua giusta
ma ecco sono più dai miei ragazzi allora
qua pieno di gente
questo ci ha un po goduto nel forza cosa
guarda un po di estasi però vabbè una
sega è quello che dovreste farvi tutti
invece di farsi spaventare però farmaci
è entrato qua ma io ripercorre le stanze
di prima effettivamente quindi sono
ovviamente ci sono già entrato con la
differenza che cazzo ne so io vi ho
avuto un ho avuto un flash voto feci
fruibile qua sotto c'è un passaggio
ho avuto un flash pazzesco del 2013 con
il flash di guerra
va bene tutto di york e ha già giocato
figurazione o me li ricordo però non mi
ricordo come faceva sbloccarlo allora
qua c'era un tendone prima a c'è un
tizio è il signor crepe in quello mi sa
credo non aspetta ok esce un libro che
libro per bambini
meno male che hai messo a libro per
bambini che poi sono spariti li si ke
devo fà via via fuori alle palle aiuto è
successo basta una palla gigante ma
certo la macchina che traspariva minima
a c'era una leva che ho tirato
io ci avrei messo un po di
monetizzazione visto video perché non
siete uomini del business faccio mi
faccio dei giri tipo vado in giro qua
c'è un'altra leva questa comparsa prima
non c'era rassicuro eccolo
yes me lo ricordavo store costo non so
perché bene siamo arrivati perché deve
esserci una transizione santo di dio
buongiorno cielo una transizione
effettivamente non l'avevo visto e va
beh sì però è piano con le magie signor
potter e la bacchetta scegliere il mago
[Applauso]
tanto e caso due casi due io mica
pulisco non ho capito se c'è lui fox
dove vi posso buttare giù mi suicidio
c'è una leva attenzione
papà fango allora prima questa ok poi
questa verde perché quella che ho
buttato della seconda si poi quella rock
no no poi questa di prima scusate sto
morendo tra l'altro e poi l'ultima
perché pian piano muore st stanza caso
intenditore di vini il number one
d'italia proprio lui il signor fari sono
astemio siamo ragazzi let's go ma le ho
fatto tutte ok siamo entrati nell'ultima
cioè questa è questa il laboratorio del
laboratori governo oddio labirinto degli
specchi lega sto male che devo fare
no c'è del sangue aiuto c'è il sangue
non è non è una zona amica globo
frantumato sembra essere esploso
dall'interno menez
me ne sbatto totalmente siringa
etichettata come tranquillante beh in
questo momento non sarebbe neanche male
però a vado di qua ok sega ossa anche
questo posso per tagliare il pane meno
male mai spiegato c'è un altro globo
dovrà aggiungerlo al sicuro è la madonna
che i senatori sono usciti da sotto o no
no
frate o per rifarmi snow corni gestito
il coro corro corro e va bene correndo
rcs in sé in volte col pavia di porco
demone mi segue a prescindere a cucinare
a guardarlo perché sono ti segue uguale
così ne frega niente aiuto di stato
toccato l'ho toccato solo forte a quando
c è 3 testa di golia ma separato che
cazzo sei fare clienti soccorrendolo
funziona aia che si celebra rigua il
maleficio
mi chiamo pesoli grana magia così
potente bastava un flip and
non sta tornando tutto regalo un castone
sotto 2008 e non posso dare io spero che
caschi il pavimento perché non so dove
cazzo vado si provano anche perché non
lo so non so dovevo correre in mezzo al
fuoco bene non era cosa più naturale da
fare effettivamente dal vantaggio in
corso ok chi la porta a porta a cazzo
via via fuori dalle balle non rifarmi
tutto al contrario aiuto pure il cammino
pure camino dove vado è tutta in fiamme
che falle e mettere un cazzo di
estintore in casa ma ti pare
se succede sto casino poiché fi tale va
dalle volpi nata o tirata servetto qua
ma con un bordello
guarda che si scioglie il pronto è pure
dietro
no mi chiamo
eppure la cura e le leve in ordine ma
siete pazzi lungo le leve in ordine come
faccio a uno no all 11 o sbagliato 123
minchia nelle vie in ordine di mancavano
ragazzi sicuramente aiuta la bei ancora
andando non hanno il nonno più a fuoco
tra qui frate frate frate fatti un paio
di cazzi tuoi totali proprio sulla porta
tutti la porta fatto che si faccia come
fate entrare ammazzati a deve colpire
cose se non muore e morto aperta porta è
morto
minchiate vale via pure balle mia
viaggianti a milioni di giro che mai va
bene e va beh buon compleanno fratello
questa sua festa però non so bene come
accendere le candeline mi dai la mano
che manca l'accendino no va bene e ave
dai mi sembra questa scelta caselle
flori slava tutto al contrario
sto male no vabbè ma fermi io leverei un
po meno di vino fosse poi perché è pieno
qua no peso morto questo senso molto
come faccio io salgo qua ok salito
sono fatte non ci sono il tasto per
saltare renditi conto cosa devo fare
ce l'ha fatta a prima porta dove vada
non corre non so cosa farei un supporto
non voglio non sapete fare è satana
minchia regali neanche la post fight di
porta nella così bella se lo facciamo
devo farti colpire con l'affare madonna
di dio devo andare a piranha che male
non solo preso in faccia piena e ma
vedevo rarità come faccio a non dare
quindi sono ho capito l'abitudine
devo farti colpire quell'affare league
ok ciao ciao non so come ma te lo farò
colpire dai non l'ha colpito in un nulla
spara a prada è yes l'ho colpito
abbiamo preso pure lui testa di culo
bruton fame dovutamente sotto che lo fa
c'è un altro nel mezzo
dribbling
aiuto
c'è però sta qua madonna che mira
perfetto chi lascia arrivo una posta poi
morto nostro che non è morto frezzato
l'ultimo vicino a porta all'ultimo
la chiave dove l'ha lasciata pensate
stato tutto sto casino non usare la
chiave che ho puntato all'inizio gioca
male che sa aperta senza la chiave mi
aspettavo di vedere un giardino pieno di
elementi verde però fa niente
è la madonna
cosa che la fa e proprio ma è proprio il
finale si è schiantata roma in faccia
utile
sono morto sono vivo io non mi ricordo
il finale e questo a me lo ricordo
invece me lo ricordo non ricordo ci
siamo siamo vivi ragazzi siamo vivi e
vegeti certo di sangue ma fa niente
sono pronti è bella stanza comunque cosa
come no ma non posso non posso più farmi
le seghe è stata non ero io era una
città bibaj crede meno signori un
bell'horror veramente è stato come fare
un tuffo in the first sono bello non
belgio mi mi ricordavo effettivamente
era un bel gioco si vede proprio che è
vecchio come in bianche però ultimamente
ragazzi non so se avete notato ma ci sto
prendendo gusto di fare titoli che hanno
segnato un po il mio canale perché
questa è una pietra miliare del canale
io cioè per me lo è perché
ha segnato un po quella che è stata la
mia evoluzione iniziale del canale
quindi tutti quei video che all'inizio
mi hanno fatto prendere piede per poi
diventare il presidente degli stati
uniti
spero vi sia piaciuto il video sono
riuscito ad avere meno questa linea g
ragazzi mischiati a casa mi è piaciuto
lasciate mazzette momento vi piace noi
come sempre comunque ci vediamo hanno
proferito da ragazzi
[Musica]